From an alternate Zurg twist, to a monkey
version of Sox, and even more Pizza Planet
easter eggs, Pixar's Lightyear was originally
a very different movie!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing everything Pixar
deleted from Lightyear.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
The big twist in Lightyear comes when the
identity of Zurg is revealed and it turns
out he's an older version of Buzz from an
alternate timeline.
When Buzz finally achieved 100% hyperspeed,
the event split the timeline – notice these
two bursts of energy which occur at that very
moment.
The second Buzz travelled centuries into the
future and discovered a ship with advanced
alien technology, an enormous mecha robot
suit, and Zyclops robots who mispronounced
his name as Zurg.
But when older Buzz, aka Zurg, opens his robot
"suit", main timeline Buzz initially mistakes
him for his father because of his similar
but aged features.
Originally, Pixar planned for the twist in
Lightyear to be that Zurg had indeed been
Buzz's father all along, which would have
matched the same reveal in Toy Story 2.
You killed my father!
No, Buzz.
I AM your father.
No!
Director Angus MacLane explained that during
the movie's development, they spent a lot
of time laying the groundwork and hints to
the big reveal that Zurg was in fact Buzz's
dad.
But when the payoff came, it felt incredibly
unsatisfying, because it was too obvious from
all the clues that had been teased for at
least the first hour of the movie.
On top of that, there was the fact that everyone
who'd ever seen Toy Story 2 knew this twist
about Zurg had already been played as a Star
Wars joke in that movie.
So, in the end, MacLane decided it would be
more interesting if the twist was that Zurg
was a version of Buzz himself, but one that
went on a different, darker path.
So, Buzz turns out to basically be his own
worst enemy.
The director said he was inspired by Indiana
Jones And Raiders of the Lost Ark where the
French archaeologist who works with the Nazis
tells Indy that he's just a slightly different
version of him.
I am a shadowy reflection of you.
It would take only a nudge to make you like
me.
I can see that having Zurg as Buzz's father
would have been way too predictable, and the
Disney animated series Buzz Lightyear of Star
Command already spoofed the Toy Story 2 revelation
in favour of making Zurg a straight-up villain,
unrelated to Buzz…
There's something you must know.
I am your father.
Psych!
Made you look, you dimwit!
…so Lightyear's filmmakers likely felt they
wanted to do something different to that particular
take in the new movie as well.
A firm fan favourite in the new movie is the
hilarious, robotic cat Sox.
Sox.
Pfft.
You're inhibiting my visuals.
Oh, sorry, is this better?
Negative.
OK, how about this.
Pfft.
But, originally, the filmmakers were going
to have a monkey as Buzz's cute animal sidekick
instead.
The idea for a monkey came from how NASA and
other space agencies have sent monkeys and
other primates into space as part of research
into space travel.
The filmmakers planned on having a type of
helper monkey who would assist Buzz on his
missions.
In the end though they found a robotic cat
was funnier than a monkey…
Sox, how long were we gone?
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow…
Bee-boop, Bee-boop, Bee-boop, Bee-boop, Bee-
…and so they ended up with Sox and his amusing
animatronic style of movement and commentary.
Buzz, that was utterly terrifying and I regret
having joined you.
The Pizza Planet truck and franchise, which
first appeared in Toy Story, has made an appearance
in almost every Pixar movie so far.
Lightyear is no exception and a pizza delivery
vehicle makes a tricky-to-spot cameo in the
scene where Buzz and Sox are fleeing the Star
Command police.
As they drive down the highway you can see
the iconic Pizza Planet rocket on top of a
truck parked up, and a guy delivering some
pizzas.
But originally, as we can see from this unused
concept art, there were also plans to show
scenes with Pizza Planet stores and locations
on the new planet, giving us more of an insight
into the layout of this new world and how
people were living there.
And apparently in another deleted scene, Buzz
would have "gone grocery shopping" after he
ran out of his pre-assigned meals.
There was going to be a joke where Buzz asked
for a packet of "dinner" - like the meal boxes
he was used to eating -, but after his many
years away, food has changed and he ended
up being sold something called "pobbles" which
MacLane described as "spiky, space" food.
The concept art also has some references to
the green aliens who Buzz first met at Pizza
Planet in Toy Story.
Who's in charge here?
The claw!
Some fans have been disappointed they didn't
make an appearance in Lightyear, especially
as some of the Little Green Men worked for
Star Command in the animated series.
However, MacLane has explained that he didn't
think it made sense for them to appear in
Lightyear, a movie that Andy saw before the
events of Toy Story.
As the aliens don't know who Buzz is when
he pops up in their claw machine in Toy Story,
it fits that they shouldn't have met him previously
in the new prequel movie.
MacLane has confirmed though that there is
an easter egg to the squeeze-toy aliens in
the first mid-credits scene, where you can
see a little statue of one of the green men
on Commander Burnside's shelf.
And, if you're a fan of the hilarious Little
Green Men or you're enjoying this video so
far, do leave a thumbs-up, I really appreciate
it.
When Zurg confronts Buzz for the first time
and corners him, Buzz is saved when the Junior
Zap Patrol blast the villain to the floor.
As Zurg recovers, he uses his arm controls
to call on a team of Zyclops to help him trap
Buzz.
The original storyboard for this sequence
reveals a hilarious little deleted moment
where the Zurg-bots can be seen chilling out
in a lounge on the ship, playing cards and
pool together, just before Zurg's command
activates them.
Also cut from the final movie was a scene
involving a killer robot hound that Zurg had
sent to hunt Buzz in the future.
In this deleted rainy action sequence, which
has shades of Blade Runner, Buzz would have
had a special briefcase with a weapon though
it completely failed to stop the canine antagonist
and he ended up getting caught by the robot
dog.
Lightyear also made some significant changes
to Zurg's design compared to the Toy Story
movies.
This Zurg is more robot-like, influenced by
anime and mecha, and his huge size was intended
to make him incredibly intimidating.
This more robotic look also meant Pixar ditched
the cape Zurg wore in Toy Story 2.
No capes!
Losing Zurg's colourful cape, however, meant
this version of the villain was heavy on purple
and The Art of Lightyear book reveals some
of Zurg's early designs which included a lot
of red and other colours.
These were discarded eventually and instead
red accents were given to Zurg via decals,
pinstripes and labels.
Zurg's horns were also reduced in size to
appear "less devil-like".
And this Zurg also got an enormous extendable
hand, akin to a claw, possibly a nod to the
Little Green Men from Toy Story.
The claw!
The Art of Lightyear book also reveals some
interesting alternate designs for Commander
Burnside where he had a bionic arm, which
implies there's an interesting backstory for
Burnside that we didn't get to see.
Curiously enough, there was also another character
with a bionic arm who ended up cut from the
film.
As well as scrapping a storyline which showed
how Buzz became a Space Ranger in the first
place, and a sequence which featured him ending
up in a Star Command brig over rivalry and
insults, the Art of Lightyear book also reveals
a lot of deleted characters that never made
it into the final movie.
There were some Miyazaki-inspired helper machines
called Minerbots that would have presumably
appeared when Buzz and the Zap Patrol went
to the mining plant on the dark side of the
planet.
There are also all of these unused characters
which the concept art book reveals as being
"Out of Picture".
And if you'd like to get a copy of The Art
of Lightyear with all of these cool designs,
and a lot more concept art, including the
original designs for Buzz Lightyear, before
Toy Story, when he was called Lunar Larry,
you can tap here to get the book with free
worldwide shipping.
I'll also add a link in the video description
below.
So, Movie Lovers, what do you think of the
big Zurg twist in Lightyear?
And is there anything you wish had been in
the final movie?
Let me know in the comments.
Next, tap here to discover more Pixar deleted
scenes like the crazy alternate ending of
Turning Red.
And be sure to like, subscribe, and tap the
bell so you don't miss out on my next Pixar
video.
Thanks for enjoying Lightyear with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!